if you like apple products and you don't
know who mark german is you definitely
should because he is hands down the most
reliable apple leaker or analyst as you
can see right here 87 accurate with over
500 rumors which is mind-blowing making
him the most reliable apple leaked
source now mac rumors just came out with
their new mac rumors podcast and they
had mark german as a guest which is
awesome and is totally legendary and
within that podcast he revealed a ton of
details about what we should expect from
apple in 2022 as you can see there he is
mark german and to be honest i've gotta
admit that i was wrong on a couple of
the topics and mac related devices
coming out this year because he went in
depth and revealed some very
mind-blowing details that i was not
expecting so instead of you guys
watching this full 1 hour and 11 minute
podcast i'm actually gonna take this
video and break down all the interesting
details that he mentioned into a short
and easy to consume video along with my
own thoughts on those apple products and
what's actually going to be coming and i
think this is important because the
podcast so far doesn't have that many
views only 2.5 k after four hours so a
lot of you guys are gonna miss that so
hopefully this video is gonna be
interesting for you guys so let's go
ahead and get into those details now the
first apple device that mark german
discussed was of course the redesigned
m2 macbook air and markerman says it's
going to be coming with an 8 core cpu
just like the m1 but a little bit faster
but it's going to be coming with a 10
core gpu so you're going to get a bigger
increase there now as far as the ports
mark german said that the macbook air is
not going to have an sd card slot it's
not going to have hdmi but it is going
to come with the new mac save 3 from
these new macbook pros and it's also
going to come with a couple of usbc
thunderbolt 4 ports and as far as the
display he's not sure if it's going to
be coming with mini led or not so that's
still in the air right now and very
interestingly he also discussed the
question of the notch and right now he's
not sure if it's going to get a notch or
not but based on everything he's been
seeing he said that he would be shocked
if there is no notch on the new macbook
air now what makes this interesting is
that in a previous video that i made i
showed off a macbook air without a notch
because leaks apple pro said that he
leaked apple cads without any kind of
notch but he recently came out with a
new apple manufacturing report for the
m2 air redesign and he can now confirm
that apple has decided to stick with the
notch design so i think there's actually
a pretty good chance that we do get a
notch and mark also thinks that the
notch is going to be a good idea because
it's gonna allow apple to give it the
same display size but shrink down the
chassis size to make it smaller and
lighter and mark also mentioned that he
wouldn't be surprised if it's just
called the macbook no more air because
it's gonna be pretty powerful with the
m2 chip and he also thinks that it's
going to take a lot of design cues from
the consumer level 24-inch m1 imac which
means we could get those off-white
bezels and the keyboard and the next
product they discussed was the
entry-level macbook pro which mark
german previously talked about in his
reports because they didn't think it
would make sense in the lineup but he
thinks it totally makes sense because it
would fill that price gap between the
1300 m1 pro right now and the 2 000 14
inch model so apple needs something kind
of in between maybe around 1 500 but the
crazy thing that he mentioned that i
totally didn't expect was that it could
be coming with the same design as the m1
macbook pro except without the touch bar
and with the m2 chip of course now i was
not expecting that because i figured
that apple would give it the same 14
inch chassis with the new design and the
notch so i guess we're gonna have to see
but that is very interesting now moving
further to the next product we have the
larger imac and it's interesting because
this time within this podcast he said
that there's a good chance that it could
actually be called the imac pro which is
very good news but unfortunately he
still fully believes that it's only
going to come with the m1 pro and the m1
max chips and not the duo which is
totally not what i was expecting because
i figured apple would be doing that
because of that little leak we found
with the bottom of the m1 max chip
showing the die to die interconnect so
it looks like from his point of view
that's only going to be coming on the
mac pro which would be very
disappointing and he also confirmed that
it's likely that it's going to be coming
with 64 gigs of ram as the limit just
like the macbook pro so that's a little
bit disappointing and then going further
he discussed the high-end mac mini and
just like the imac he also thinks that
the high end could come with the same m1
pro and m1 max chips and he even thinks
there's a chance that they could call it
the mac mini pro just to make the whole
lineup make more sense with the regular
low end mac mini and then the pro model
with the pro and max chips so that would
be awesome for marketing and then if
you're interested in the 24 inch imac he
also believes that the new m2 version of
that imac is not going to be coming
until next year which is 2023 which
perfectly falls in line with my own
expectations just based on how apple
delays the imac compared to the other
macs and now let's get right into the
mac pro which is what they discuss next
and mark german personally believes that
the modularity of the mac pro is going
to take a massive hit which means you're
not going to be able to replace as many
parts as you can with the current mac
pro and as far as the design this one is
a total mind-blowing detail for me
because he says it's going to be half
the size of the current mac pro
but he thinks it's going to be around
three or four mac minis stacked on top
of each other with a very clean design
on the front
with the back having a ton of holes for
cooling and a ton of ports now this is
very interesting because way back in may
of 2021 he changed his mind about the
cube design and he said that it could
look like a smaller version of the
current mac pro
but now it looks like he's changing his
mind again potentially and going with
the cube design moving forward so it's
very interesting and it's awesome that
he's confirming that right now and as
far as the naming this time in this
podcast he actually mentioned that it
could be called the m1 max duo chip or
the m1 max cuadro so it's awesome that
he finally referred to it as that
because that's what we have been talking
about for the last couple of months
referring to the m1 max quadro in our
personal videos now moving on we have
the m2 ipad pro and mark mentioned that
it's going to be getting a bit of a
redesign with the introduced max safe
charging and the glass back now in terms
of how the mag safe charging is going to
work mark mentioned two different
possibilities the first possibility is
that it's going to have the magsafe 3
charger from the macbook pro right next
to the usbc port or the second option is
the puck style that we currently have on
the back of the iphone so he thinks it
could perfectly match just to help push
max safe and max safe accessories
forward and between those two options he
thinks it's gonna be the puck style max
safe wireless charging on the back just
to push wireless charging forward and
push mac safe accessories and all of
that so that you're gonna be able to
charge your air pods your apple watch
your iphone on the back of the ipad and
we just made a video on that topic so if
you haven't seen that along with all the
patents that we showed off definitely
check out that video the first topic in
terms of the apple watch they talked
about was the rugged watch now mark
believes that the regular base watch
right now is aluminum so it can still
get dented so he's saying that what you
want is a more rugged casing to prevent
those dents and he says that it's going
to look very cool and a ton of people
are going to be buying it just for the
look so he says it could potentially
look like a g-shock or a cassia watch
which is very interesting but then one
of the guys at mac rumors asked him
about the pricing on this new rugged
edition and he said that he believes
it's gonna be a higher end more
expensive model potentially with a third
larger screen size which has been in the
leagues from ross young so it might
actually be a more expensive higher end
and if this happens it could even
potentially be the series 8 pro that i
made a video about recently so
definitely check that out and i'm not
sure about that but it could definitely
happen at a higher more expensive price
point so that's very interesting and if
you're interested in the health sensors
of the apple watch he says that apple
has recently been testing a body
temperature sensor for basically
checking your temps and letting you know
if you're having a fever or if you're
too cold or something like that but he
says that discussion on that has died
down so there is a chance that it might
get delayed and on top of that there's
also the blood pressure sensor that
apple is working on but he believes that
might come in 2023 or even 2024
and finally we have the whole blood
glucose sensor that everybody's been
going crazy about but he believes that's
very far away potentially 2025 or 2026
so we should probably just forget about
that for now now moving forward let's
get into the iphone se 2 that we're
expecting this spring and he says that
this is going to be a big deal
especially for the up and coming markets
like the indian market because it's
going to be at a lower price but he
thinks it's just going to get a newer
chip and added 5g but it's gonna stick
to the same exact design that we have
right now so that's a little bit
disappointing and in terms of the future
mark believes that we'll be getting a
new iphone sc with a larger display and
probably face id because we can't stick
to touch id forever and dylan dkt
actually came out with some leaks about
this earlier today and dylan believes
that that new design is coming in
2024 with a major update and he
confirmed that this year's se is gonna
have 5g and a small spec update with the
same design so that's definitely a
little bit more disappointing for us who
were hoping for a better design and now
with that said they moved on to the
iphone 14 and the first thing to mention
is that there will not be a mini iphone
14 model which we were already expecting
and mark confirmed that we are going to
be getting a hole punch on the iphone 14
pro models which we were also expecting
and hoping for and on top of that we
could be seeing those new satellite
features for emergency calling and
texting like we were hearing about
before now this next detail is very
interesting and i was not expecting to
hear this from mark but he believes that
pretty soon apple is gonna drop the
iphone numbers and just stick to a
simple naming scheme so he believes
we're gonna have the iphone and then the
iphone max which is basically an iphone
with the same features but just a larger
display and then we're gonna have the
iphone pro with the upgraded features
and then the iphone pro max with no
numbers and then of course we have the
iphone se below that and then in the
future he says we're gonna have the
iphone fold so let's get right into
those details in terms of when that
should come out he believes it's going
to be 2023
or 2024 but he says apple is for sure
working on this and dealing dkt actually
came out and confirmed that apple has
been recently waiting and watching the
foldable market to make sure that it's
not going to die off as a small niche or
get irrelevant to make sure that they
should actually make a foldable iphone
but they are working on different
prototypes as well and they're waiting
because the technology right now isn't
there just yet to make it a really nice
product because there are too many
compromises that still exist with
foldable displays so apple is basically
playing the long game now moving on to
apple's ar and vr headset situation he
says that apple has over 2 000 people
working on their new mixed reality
headsets and the ar glasses for a few
years from now and he says that this new
product is going to require a new
operating system maybe called ros and in
terms of the release date for the next
vr headset mark believes that wwdc in
june makes the most sense because apple
needs major developer support to get all
the new apps and everything ready for
launch kind of like the apple silicon
announcement in wwc of 2020 before the
launch of the first m1 max because apple
needed developers to get all that
software work ready so i totally agree
with mark on this and i believe it's
coming this june an interesting detail
mark mentioned was that this is going to
be apple's biggest product in seven
years so apple really wants people to
try on the headsets and experience it
for themselves in person which means it
would require an in-person event so if
apple can pull that off in june then it
should be wwdc for sure and in terms of
what to expect from the upcoming vr
headset he says that it's going to be
very expensive and it's going to focus
on three different things with the first
one being communication so he thinks
apple's going to create a memoji-like
zoom experience for meetings and that
it's gonna be a very big deal and then
there's gonna be media consumption so
like watching movies shows and videos
like youtube videos and then finally
there's gonna be gaming so he says apple
could potentially have their own aaa
gaming studio in-house working on new
games which is going to be awesome and
now with that out of the way we have the
new airpods pro 2 and they had a little
bit of discussion about the stemless
design but i think he believes we could
still have those short stems from the
current airpods pro and he actually
mentioned one of the leaked designs of
the airpods pro case that had speaker
grills on the bottom for find my and
this little loop thing for accessories
and he says that that would actually be
a great idea for apple to do because
apple can then sell more accessories
like an apple loop in different colors
to make extra revenue and i think that
totally makes sense and if that leak is
true then there's a good chance that the
design of the airpods pro 2 could stay
the same but with upgraded internals
like better speaker drivers and better
chips better battery life better
software and maybe even ultra wide band
to replace bluetooth to give us lossless
audio which i recently made a video on
and i think you would really enjoy it if
you check it out and now to my surprise
mark actually believes that apple could
come out with updated airpods max which
i did not expect at all in new color
variations now i personally just got air
pods max and i love them but it sucks
knowing that they might actually update
them later this year and i think that it
could happen in december since that's
when the original airpods max came out
and that might be a good idea for apple
as kind of like a christmas sales boost
or potentially apple could end up
delaying them by another year and in
terms of the upgrades apple could make
to the next gen airpods max mark
believes that there's a chance they
could ditch lightning and switch to usbc
only and give it better battery life but
he says there are definitely some
upgrades that apple can make and in my
personal opinion i think that there's a
very good chance that apple is gonna add
lossless audio support both wired and
wireless with potential ultra wide band
replacing bluetooth but that's just my
opinion as well so hopefully that
happens so there you guys go i just
wrapped up that full an hour and 11
minute podcast with all the juicy
details into this much shorter video so
if you appreciate that and if you
enjoyed this or learned something new
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out those videos i
mentioned right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]